hey guys I'm Ryan right and I'm Brianna
white yep
there's her name so Brianna and I today
are gonna check out a video from olan
Rogers going zombie now this is
Brianna's first time on the channel
I met her oh how old were you when I met
you twelve twelve Wow yeah so we've
known each other for quite some time we
just started to actually get to know
each other today like the real cells of
us and I gotta say like totally not an
interesting person so boring
she's so boring worst person no passion
no Drive worst and on top of that too I
make her look better because you know
like I'm next to her so when people see
such a good-looking guy then they see
this that's why I'm here
yeah yeah you want if you want to feel
better by yourself I'd be next to a
good-looking guy yeah because you
clearly why would you be confident about
your looks
no reason now is the time you're kidding
no I kid every once in a while okay you
double weird improv viewers what we
developed over the years
let's check this video out
my shows are tied why should I die what
what are you doing I gotta waste these
good I gotta lay some there's no time
there there's a zombie zeroing in we got
a great
we got a zombie here yeah um be over
he's my god slop over there look at this
but yeah what is he doing he's walking
so slow the sloth really yeah look he's
taking a nap but he's taking a nap he's
taking it ha ha ha ha I've never seen
this what is he doing where did he get
the pillow he pulled out a pillow nappy
it's like he lost his keys and then gave
up it almost looks like he doesn't have
like anything to watch on Netflix he's
watched it all listen I'm gonna be
honest I think we actually have plenty
of time before this guy gets over here
what do we uh what do we do what can't
we do how much better either
3434 yep what are you 25 I won't gonna
say anything but I think our zombie has
eyes for you can you fetch me a sweet
tea beer beer fetch me a sweet tea bum
bag can you get myself a little bit of
sugar
Shmi sweet tea [ __ ] yeah you think I
would totally go zombie you would go
zombie I would go zombie in a heartbeat
why goes on date I like their carefree
add to it you know look at this guy
today consists of nothing but eating
people we well we all can't be perfect
what's gonna happen when somebody gets
up and doesn't look like he cares I
don't think so I don't think he cares
we'll go over there and let them bite
you this no zombie burger what this is a
big decision it's not like popping a bag
of popcorn get over there Hey
I just can't believe we're doing this
I mean I'm no southern boy you were
bombing yeah well you know when you get
over there you know are you really gonna
go through with this yeah I think so I
think I will protip
what do you tie those shoes oh yeah yeah
oh no force here oh this could be my
final form I gotta look good I could
look nice it's not a Pokemon this is
kind of the same thing I don't want to
be star you my whole life I want to be a
Bulbasaur screw both us what a
buh-buh-buh-buh source Rex isn't a BB in
a Pokemon are you approached about
trainer Thor is super close does this
even matter
oh crap yeah here leap wait why are you
handing me leave in case I get blood on
me you're gonna go to wipe it off or
something I don't want to walk around
with stains in case I can't watch this I
can't we do this all right all right all
right okay
oh crap my shoe Thor oh gosh dang it
Thor mail for me we have this whole
thing work oh oh oh my oh no oh oh
leave the leaf the leaf I gave the lived
oh okay okay this is not me this is not
me I'm a store you I totally am a star
you I touch that I thought it was
beautiful
oh that's dark I think okay I think
you're ready for your table they want it
I mean Thor got to eat somebody you know
Thomas tinium really good to look he
turned away and you know I got to
experience what his hobby was me and
I've actually never seen any of this
guys gets before I thought it was pretty
funny I mean it kind of overstay its
welcome a little bit yeah I like these
are my favorite kind of skits and short
films on YouTube are the ones that feel
just like cooked up you know not like
yeah doesn't feel like they got like a
huge crew assembled and like they spend
forever in it like the ones where
there's such a vibrant energy to what
they're doing and stuff because some of
those clips you're like those are
clearly like outtakes or something but
they can't stop laughing yeah exactly
it's too real too authentic yeah I'd be
interested in checking out more of this
guy's sketches I think you'd be a great
actress for such things
yeah because you've got a pretty wacky
sense of humor yeah like [ __ ] insane
a little bit a little bit you know one
time I pulled a joke on Rihanna
gonna talk about this yeah it wasn't
just on there's not a lot of people the
true story if you guys already were
questionable about whether or not you
should like me get ready to dislike me
even more my friend Brandon Mel go
owner of a restaurant called spice said
while he was in El Salvador that you
know it would be funny if he if we told
everyone that he died it was like I was
like [ __ ] hilarious let's do it but
some things are funny when you're
talking about them in imagination not
through actually executing it Briona
after the myspace post my space this is
my space it was a long time she believed
it and I ruined her holidays her dad did
not like me really did not yeah yeah but
I learned my lesson not to believe
everything you read on the Internet
should have known from the beginning
yeah because I'm a major contribution to
things that are not true on the Internet
but I'm sorry Brianna I'm really sorry I
forgave you a long time you know the
blood looks actually really good yeah
great color
I like this get set up of you know this
person falling in love with a zombie and
oh god that music just got you right
here
really again and he gets you down there
too buzz zinging I mean a penis joke I
was wondering how long you're gonna hold
that yeah the onion music in the
background fantastic choice I felt that
they did things that you know like a lot
of people try to do Sambi comedies
nowadays or zombies and there were
things in there where I was like hey
that's actually a pretty funny touch to
it I like what if I like more of the
humor when it dealt with the zombies
more and more than just yeah like I like
when the opening ones are like they have
so much time because while watching The
Walking Dead have always thought that
like those zombies are kind of slow you
got plenty yeah yeah so I kind of like
that too and the shoelace bit like over
my favorite moments and I would have
preferred a little bit more of that but
know that it's [ __ ] hilarious is way
better than anything I've ever put
together so yeah good for you man anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to it
you can subscribe to the real rejects
brianna is an actress slash
soon-to-be youtuber mm-hmm and it's
gonna be gaming related can't believe
that [ __ ]
whoa so you could check out in the
meantime her Facebook page her fan page
there's our modeling photos on there
yeah there's modeling photos on there
those modeling photos have certain
photos that men will like absolutely
yeah
and ladies too well ladies feel jealous
if they look at these photos yeah I'd
like to thanks man these are the photos
you want to check out mm-hmm I just
thought if your dad was watching I do oh
my god don't say that I wanted to Claire
specifically when I was talking about
yeah and you can share a Facebook page
and you can subscribe to her channel in
the meantime cuz wait for those videos
to come up because we're gonna take a
look at some footage she's shot already
and you can follow the real rejects on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope follow us on our social
networks because if we get enough
followers we can get even more product
placement for things such as laptop
cases laptop cases are great they hold
your laptop the charger and also um in
case you want to sneak into a Starbucks
and possibly like do with your
girlfriend excuse me for a second
and possibly do it with your girlfriend
you can put all your sex toys in the
laptop case people will think oh you're
in Starbucks you just got a laptop you
know one of the MacBook Pros but then
you take out the sex toys in the
bathroom with your girl and you get to
use that dildo and she gets to use that
strap-on you I'm so sanitary yeah then
you flush the toilet okay well yeah
laptop